hello freak [ __ ] that's work it's
weird but isn't this look like life in
general
yeah it's slippery yeah there's there's
I mean it's like we're talking about
with abortion like what is it is it
killing a baby yep or is it a medical
procedure you know they all just agree
that it's both but like that I don't
understand why there is especially in
this country like it's so so polarizing
here you know they're probably not a
debate no oh come on man I know populate
Dawkins had tweeted something about it
that there's nothing did people like a
human embryo was essentially the same
thing as a pig embryo like ridiculous
comparison to abortion well it's the
religious right we'll always be crazy
about the things that it's crazy about
and people will always get offended on
Twitter when Richard Dawkins tweet
something that sounds like oh by the way
I have an interview with him coming up
if so if you don't let me just plug if
you don't subscribe to we two people
live and search for we two people all
one word and your podcast app I'll be
talking to Sam Harris tomorrow which
will get released in a couple of weeks
and don't shout at me for not releasing
it immediately like you did last time
Twitter and don't have some not to shove
it we'll have some good now that there
right the exactly first rumor right it's
true I'm gonna sue their asses and I'm
dragging through court and I'll be
talking to Joe about I'll be doing
launching a little um ask me anything
till dawn end this and so I had dot I
did a whole i-20 Dawkins had a stroke
he's great he's fine he's doing well
well the stroke did not affect his his
cognitive function none did affect his
ability to sing which is interesting
oh that's an extra tune yeah and it's so
there are a few motor functions that I
think it's affected but it didn't did
yet as you say it didn't affect his
cognitive so that'll be being released
so follow at wtp underscore live on tone
after an underscore go find it just find
Olivia's people anyway so what Richard
Dawkins was saying and is people are
going to be angry at him on Twitter
regardless of what he says but I still
affirm that in the state in the state's
the conversation around abortion is
uniquely different from the way that it
is in Europe and in Australia it's much
more of a it's just much more of a fault
line issue and I wonder whether in
hindsight it wouldn't have been better
for roe v wade not to actually have been
decided by the supreme court that way
right well just because i know people
going to get on overworld you [ __ ]
cisgender piece of [ __ ] i believe i
believe in abortion surrogate mama leave
in abortion rights but i don't believe
that it's that you can find in the
constitution of the united states a
right so inalienable that the supreme
court like where is it in the
Constitution the supreme court said
there's a right to privacy therefore
there's a right to abortion because we
don't want to interfere in women's
affairs but that presupposes that the
embryo isn't a human you don't have the
right to privacy to kill somebody right
I mean if I go into a room my right to
privacy doesn't extend to me get being
able to get away with killing a baby the
question of whether or not it's a baby
is the relevant question right that's
not addressed at you know in in Roe so I
think that it should be legal but I
think that it should be legal through
the legislative process I think that is
a legitimate Democratic aspiration for
people to be able to and if it means
that it's not legal in Alabama because a
majority of people in Alabama don't want
it I don't think the founding fathers
would have a problem with that well
there's a strong amount of the large
amount of people that don't want men
talking about this at all yeah well feel
that you should be able no that's right
this yes that's the advantage of the
problem that is one of the main problems
in the email issue no I understand a
woman being upset that a man with no
stake in the game is stepping up and
saying that a woman shooter should not
be able to have an abortion well why I
mean how do I have stake in the game of
whether or not for example murder should
be legal okay this is not that this is
this is something different this is no
more if there's nothing to raise a moral
question it might be to you but it might
not be to them if it's just having like
okay here's the morning-after pill is
that the same as an abortion I don't
care because I don't think there's any
normal regnant no I don't think that is
wrong with a brother is if it's a nine
month old baby the babies in there it's
about to come out the next day decide to
open her up and stab it in the head this
is what I'm arguing for is the kind of
ink
mentalism which you were just alluding
to right it's not a black or white thing
why can't we but well can't we all
appreciate that it's both because it's
become so polarized in the United States
that both positions are [ __ ] and
people on both sides know that both
positions are [ __ ] it's [ __ ] to
say that it is just a women's health
issue and has no ethical implications
whatsoever even if as you say you're
talking about cutting a woman open at
nine months and stabbing the embryo in
the head it's also [ __ ] to say that
the instant and egg is fertilized so
that is a person that should have all of
the rights to life that an adult should
have and then it's murder to kill a
blastocyst if it's smaller than the size
of the head of a pin right it's so very
consciously or stupid this is an
incremental situation life evolves it
grows a fetus grows it becomes a human
being and Peter Singer the great
philosopher also an Australian says that
under certain conditions infanticide the
killing of babies should be legal and
could be ethical well he's an animal not
he loves animals more than he but he
makes a legitimate point which is that
you know why does it make a difference
one day after the baby is born suppose
you've got a premature baby that's born
you know four weeks early
in fact now we can already make babies
survive it right right around the point
of viability which is where abortion is
still on the on the fringe of so you've
got a 22 or 23 24 week old baby they're
not not we called baby after the times
you know time from me from the moment of
Inception conception that could live
outside the womb right at the moment it
gets born it becomes murder to kill it
but you could have killed exactly the
same organism with exactly the same
future exactly the same prospects and
exactly the same life if it was inside
the womb in the relative States well
which on the road under roe v wade I'm
not talking about late term I'm talking
about the point of viability roe v wade
state of eye ability time it's been
interpreted as being like that 20 to 24
weeks so this is most difficult ever I
don't I don't think I don't know whether
or not that comes out of the actual
ruling where they were writing it in roe
v wade but I do know that that is the
way that it's been interpreted by lower
courts since then but maybe they
actually spell
number of weeks either way you know he's
pointing to it to a legitimate and
remember sort of moral hypocrisy severe
azide complicated slippery issue it's
not simple black or one right and the
idea that we shouldn't be allowed to
think and talk about the the moral
quandary of this because we can't have
babies well I'm not agreeing still I'm
not agreeing to that no and I'm saying
that is an argument that women want a
because they feel they feel like there's
this unjust sort of male dominance on
the female reproductive system look when
I see a bunch of white men white old men
sitting in Congress making rules against
women predominantly young women
predominantly young women of color who
are in areas that have less the least
amount of access which may fit on easily
women of color how so because safe legal
abortions are more difficult to obtain
in places like rural Alabama than they
are in places like New York City yeah
there's a lot of white people under
Alabama I don't just really think it's a
racial issues much a poverty issue yeah
okay like things like Planned Parenthood
and shutting down Planned Parenthood's
they're just going to affect people that
don't have much money yep who are
disproportionately people of color as
well
disproportionately in terms of the
actual numbers of human beings or
presidentís percentage-wise
a lot of the actual numbers of human
beings it's not right but you can
understand how it would look bad if you
add people of color to that it
accentuates the issue of makes it even
more problematic and makes it more of a
big left-wing progressive issue right
that can't be argued against do you
think they ought to elimination against
people of color oh don't want to do that
it's people yes human beings but do you
think that the optics would look as bad
if all of the old white men who were
writing the laws were black I think it
all looks bad I don't think I'd look as
bad the ID hold on a second you're
saying that if old white men make these
issues it doesn't look as bad not saying
it looks worth that as possible it looks
worse than one thing like and men we're
making this issue against all poor
people yeah because all the white men
just seem to drip privilege because they
you every single check box they've got
going for them they're both male their
white purse and
all day argument anyway they're tortured
argument um Aaron Thomas you don't think
it looks weird when Clarence Thomas
votes against abortion huh yeah I do
yeah so there you go but I mean my point
my point is simply I take the optics as
being a bad thing
I think the optics are worse if it's
white people and if it's black people
but I'm happy to happy to yield that
point to concede that point if that's a
sticking one the point is we have to be
able to have conversations about
anything without allowing our identities
to prevent us from being able to think I
agree with mine that I came on this show
was because I was getting into an
argument with an activist about whether
or not I had a right to have an opinion
about whether or not Stephen Colbert had
been racist right and she was claiming
that I didn't I didn't have a right to
have a conversation about it because I'm
a white man well that was just the way
she tried to get out of the argument you
know the whole thing before that was her
not understanding the joke and she
didn't want to own up to me I said she
didn't understand the joke and then when
you sort of explained it to her she was
using the U as a white man thing to try
to deny your opinion don't you think it
happens all the time I mean what and
you're just literally saying I think
we're both on the same page here in that
I think we both agree that you should
absolutely be able to have a
conversation about this the question is
should a man be able to decide what a
woman can and can't do with the body and
should we be able to make the laws so
you just smuggled in the term with her
body well it is a baby if it's a
blastocyst and it is in our body right
she's I'm laughing that in her bonnet a
body right so that is a decision that
we're talking about that so when it gets
to be an embryo or a fetus along the way
somewhere along the way it ceases to be
just a body but an unrelated male human
being when should that person be able to
make a decision and should a male human
being be able to make a decision at all
because if you can make a decision about
the embryo or a fetus can you make it
about the blastocyst like when can you
decide and why should a man be able to
make that decision in the first place
because he's got because he's got a
brain as well and we're all in
controlling someone's body you are
talking about controlling a body no
which a woman would not
I was outside of her you tell her she
can't take care of that blastocyst and
remove it she must make it viable and
bring it to birth we're talking about
when Homosapien comes into existence
that's a philosophical and ethical
question no it's not if you're aiming it
as being if you're telling a woman's
body
no no because we're talking about the
rights giving someone a right or
stopping them and controlling them yeah
if you're talking about a blastocyst
inside a woman's body yeah and you're a
man you decide you don't even know this
woman you decide by your moral argument
in judgment she should not be able to
terminate that blast is's then you are
deciding what she can do with her body
no you're deciding what she can do to
the blastocyst it's in her body get
inside her body sure it's also inside
her body when it's nine months old so
you you're seriously a man unrelated man
should be able to have input on whether
a woman should know Terminator Blastoise
no I'm saying I'm saying that the
democratic institutions of the state
should be able to decide that I'm not
talking about democratic institutions
we're talking very specifically about a
man but he's a man you able to decide if
it's a dictatorship then I don't agree
with that I mean I do believe that
people should be able to I think this is
something that people ought to be able
to vote on yes I personally again favor
abortion rights but I don't think that I
don't think that the gender of the
person who is voted into power by the
voting public is relevant in terms of
whether or not the voting public thinks
that embryos are human beings but you
don't think that I don't think I don't
think that embryos have a right to life
but I don't I don't think that it makes
sense to say that an embryo is just the
woman's body we're not talking about an
embryo we're talking about the entire
process right the entire process of
conception to birth and that's somewhere
along the way what are you arguing you
arguing that if there are if there are
males in positions of power in Congress
that they should have to abstain from
ruling I'm sorry the male justices on
the Supreme Court have to abstain from
voting on abortion cases I'm arguing
that it's problematic when a man decides
who cannot get pregnant decides when a
book a baby is actually a baby so she
may not be allowed to vote sir I'm not
saying that I'm just saying candidates
that are anti-abortion don't you think
it's problematic that a guy should
decide whether it likes a for you're a
hardcore well I've already said it looks
bad why not just the uptick
his luck looks ma'am but what a
problematic mein other than looks well
it's not it's it's a huge issue that
looks it's a huge issue that's someone
who cannot get pregnant decides that
another human being that they're totally
unrelated to can't make the decision
that five cells that are bundled
together must be brought to life they
think that those five cells are a person
well they don't even know this I mean
you're just a lot of cells they don't
really know a person they don't know
this for why should they have any power
over this person and why did they have
any powers are they determining when are
they controlling a person's body and
when are they saving a baby well that's
precisely the question right there is
the question should they should a male
have the right to determine whether or
not a woman can murder her newborn baby
it's a good question I say no at least
you're consistent yeah I don't think
what in this ad a one-year-old I don't
think anybody should be able to murder a
baby I don't think a man should have the
right I think we society as a society no
collective no no you were just I thought
you were just saying that you you think
that a man should not be able to prevent
a mother from killing her baby
no that's beside that wrong what I mean
is no because that is what you're saying
with regard to the to abortion you're
saying that a man shouldn't have a
should not have the right to prevent a
woman from killing her baby very often
is when we interrupt each other it's not
going to work okay i I know what you're
saying and I know that you're saying
that we should all have a stake in this
we shall be able discuss this I just
think that when you talk about
especially like a blastocyst eventually
becoming an embryo we have to agree in
some way shape or form that you and I
don't have a stake in it we're not going
to get pregnant no it's a way it's a way
bigger issue for a woman that it is for
Matt yes so we agree we agree that it's
a way bigger issue for a woman an
also-ran they should be able to discuss
I just think we both agree that you
should be able to Skype yeah I mean yeah
well they're there I'm coming for me
very debate where I'm coming from here
is that I feel like we use identity
politics to deprive other people of
standing to discuss questions that are
actually universal because their moral
questions right I think we all have so I
one thing that I try to do as much as
possible is understand where people who
I disagree with a coming from and I know
you do that as well
so I am Pro abortion rights but in order
for me to understand where people who
detest abortion are coming from it's
necessary for me to make the sort of
leap of empathy and logic into their
camp and see things from the way that
they see them which is that the instant
an egg is fertilized for them that
becomes a sacred a sacred question of a
new life where it's no longer about the
woman's body it's now a moral and
ethical question that we're all involved
in because we're all involved in what
our culture is allowed to do and who
it's allowed to kill and how it's
allowed to kill them so it becomes a bit
more like a death penalty question where
you might say well I'm never going to be
up for the death penalty because I'm
never going to do anything that would
require that would put me on death row
so what standing do I have to be in
favor or against the death penalty
that's sort of a moot question like
we're all in this society together we
all have to figure out what's right and
wrong and if we've got a brain we should
have conversations about what's good or
bad and the fact that I'm unlikely to be
in a specific scenario doesn't actually
really give me less standing to have a
conversation about it or even to write
laws about it if people vote me into a
position where I can write laws about it
well I certainly think it does when
you're talking about a blastocyst I
certainly think it does when you talk
about the argument of conception and
when something becomes alive so let me
ask you this when do you think abortion
should be legal do you think it should
be legal up to nine months or these
things should be cut off period I think
it should basically be legal all the way
up to nine months not probably agree
with Peter Singer that maybe maybe it's
occasionally okay to kill barbers so you
said wow so you think that a viable baby
inside a woman's body at nine months old
she's fully pregnant as long as that
baby doesn't come out she should be able
to kill it well I'm saying even if it
does come out maybe it's because I'm
evil that's some ridiculous you know I
think murder a baby
well religious people think that you
know I'm not talking to all they think
that blastocysts not talking about
religious people I'm talking about you
yeah I don't
I think it's obvious that the process of
going from an egg into a Joe Rogan is
such a long and incremental passage that
I don't see any reason why 20 weeks or
22 weeks or even vaginal birth is like
the ABS
saluté morale cut off I would like what
you think though that that's weird that
you have this like really rigid opinion
on it I don't have a rigid opinion what
you have six you could kill a baby you
don't think that's rigid no because I'm
absolutely open to being convinced out
of that it's just I happen to have read
a book by Peter Singer about that and so
he sort of convinced me I mean what you
would have that you should be able to
kill a baby when it's born well that
there would be systems in place that
would like that would help mothers I
don't think that it should be I heard of
agree with Bill Clinton's old framing
that abortion should be safe legal and
rare right that you should have as many
opportunities for people not to get
pregnant in the first place widespread
concept contraception widespread sex
education and that this should not just
be a form of birth control right on the
other hand if people find themselves in
a horrible pickle and they don't know of
how to get out of it these things really
hit the baby with a rock yesterday like
years ago anyway yeah I don't know Joe
it sounds pretty horrible doesn't it it
does but again you can't get pregnant
and I can't get pregnant so that's out
it people are getting all my kids on
your rails
they're getting furious at us right now
for even discussing it because literally
we can't get pregnant they're wrong
they're wrong
but you're right no I'm right that I
should be able to talk about it but I
don't know what the answer is you
definitely should be able to talk about
it but should be able to kill a baby
with a rock
we have probably nah probably I talked
about that I'll never be on death row
maybe that's how I get on death row
killing my children it's so evil and
unsympathetic and unexplainable asto
cyst is the same Jonah
it is but you don't see that little
[ __ ] know you're the last assisters so
long you would have to have like reading
glasses on then you look at it at the
head as long as you put a comforter over
the baby so you can't see what's
happening I think what we're talking
about is a really complicated subject
[Applause]
[Music]